[MUSIC PLAYING]
- So it's my
pleasure to introduce
the first panel of
this afternoon, which
is on big data.
I alluded to it this
morning, but there
is an explosion of data at
every level of the organism
to behavioral data, like
our cell phone usage, that
can be used if you're
clever analytically,
and that has its own
challenges, to really understand
patterns of disease and
potentially prevent them.
So to lead this panel our
moderator is Caroline Buckee.
She is an assistant
professor of epidemiology
at the Harvard Chan School of
Public Health, where she's also
the associate director of the
Center for Communicable Disease
Dynamics.
Dr. Buckee's work at Harvard
uses mathematical models
to bridge the biological
scales underlying malaria
epidemiology.
She works with
experimental researchers
to understand the molecular
mechanisms within the host that
underlie disease and infection.
And uses both genomic
and mobile phone data
to link these individual
level processes
to understand population
level patterns of transit.
Please join me in
welcoming Dr. Buckee.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you.
The world is changing
very fast, as we all know.
We've all seen those
exponential graphs
showing population growth.
But population density is
also rising very quickly.
And as of 2014, more than half
the world's population was
living in an urban
environment and projections
suggest that over
the next 30 years
we will add 2.5 billion people
to our urban environments,
and 90% of those will
be in Asia and Africa.
So there's nothing a
pathogen likes more
than a densely populated slum.
And I think that
really highlights
some of the threads that
were brought up earlier today
about the importance
of embedding all
of our research in
the local populations
and national control programs in
low and middle income settings.
And in particular,
for capacity training.
So this session is on big data.
Many of us don't
really like the term
big data, although it's catchy.
So I would like to reframe
this as a discussion
about qualitatively new
types of data stream
that are often at scale, at
the level of the population.
And so yes, this requires
new computational challenges.
But I think by labeling
things big data we
can miss the fact that all
of these new data streams
are embedded within
traditional small data that
are absolutely essential.
So epidemiological information
on the ground, the importance
of community health
care workers,
like was highlighted earlier
when we discussed Ebola,
really can't be overstated.
So we do have many
new opportunities.
So I'm just going to give you
some numbers to kind of frame
how fast the pace of
technology is changing.
So it took on the order
of months or even years
to sequence a
single human genome.
In the year 2000 it
would have cost hundreds
of millions of dollars.
Now, it costs on
the order of $1,000.
And we saw this morning
from Christian's talk
that we can sequence
viral genomes which
are much, much smaller than
that for $50, even less,
over a very short time period.
We also talked about CRISPR
and the promise of gene drive
technologies for controlling
and containing diseases.
So we have this opportunity to
really fundamentally rethink
how we do diagnostics,
surveillance, and track
epidemics for containment.
Mobile phones, which we all
have now, except for some people
don't have smart phones.
But generally speaking,
everyone has a phone.
So the World Bank estimates that
in 2000, 12 out of 100 people
had mobile phone subscriptions.
Now it's 101 out of 100
people have mobile phone
subscriptions.
Clearly the distribution
is not even,
and some people have
multiple subscriptions.
But increasingly, cell
phones are everywhere.
And so not only
does it produce what
we call digital exhaust data,
behavioral data about where
everyone is, where they're
going, what they're doing,
it also creates a tool to
engage directly with people
and to educate them.
Now of course, what comes
with that is also challenges.
So we have this explosion of
disinformation, the importance
of rumors in containing
epidemics and trying
to reach people.
And so I think it also brings
up this question about where
we aim our solutions.
So designing the perfect app
isn't going to work, clearly.
We need to have cultural
specific context when
we think about engaging
populations around epidemic
containment and surveillance.
So I think the
challenges that we're
going to discuss today that
come along with the promises
that big data provide are to
do with the lack of analytics,
the lack of validation, the
need to integrate these new data
sources with
traditional epidemiology
and national control programs.
And then it also
brings up some issues
that are age old problems for
public health practitioners
like, how do we balance
individual rights, rights
to privacy, with public health?
And I would be interested to
hear your thoughts about that
too.
So our speakers, again,
you have their bios.
Our speakers are going to
range from global health
security and threats on a global
scale that are represented
by emerging diseases.
And then we're going to hear
about the national control
programs and how we can
move them forward using
new analytics and
new technologies.
And then lastly, Ami is going
to discuss with us the promise
of genomics for
helping us understand
human health as an ecosystem.
An integrated
system that reflects
the dynamics of immune systems
and our microbial communities,
and what that means for
developing new drugs
and approaches to containment.
So I will, without
further ado, I
will introduce our first
speaker Jim Wilson.
Please join me in welcoming him.
[APPLAUSE]
- OK.
So we're going to
talk about something
that is, I would say, a
little bit off the beaten path
of typical public health.
And this is the world where
public health intersects
with national security.
And I think this is
an important topic
to discuss because,
just for context here,
this is the first time I've
ever spoken about this publicly.
I've been doing this
work for 25 years.
What do I mean when I say
health security intelligence?
Why do we need
this intelligence?
I think your speakers from the
first panel amply displayed why
we need effective intelligence.
How is information used to
inform our intelligence?
What do I mean when
I say intelligence?
I'm not interested in people's
personal records, at all.
I'm not interested
in named individuals.
I'm interested in trends big
trends, scary trends, trends
that are sometimes
very hard to detect.
How do we use the intelligence?
And what are the challenges with
health security intelligence
in today's society?
I will give you a hint, they're
the exact same challenges
that Kevin outlined earlier,
as well as our first panel.
This whole aspect of
information sharing,
who gets to control
that information,
all the games people play.
You will find me to be a cynic.
You will find me to be
very frustrated and angry
with my own career
and my failure
to convince our
government and the world
to do the right damn thing.
All right, here we go.
Traditional public
health, and I'm
going to upset a
couple folks here,
as a discipline does tend
to be forensically oriented.
There is an important
reason for that.
You cannot have our CDC or
our public health officials
expressing things that are
speculative to the public.
You must have confidence.
Right?
We all in agreement?
You don't want to have
questions about your CDC.
You want to take their
word as almost the word
from some divinity, right?
To achieve that level of
confidence takes time,
takes a lot of time.
Unfortunately for us, we
continually run out of time.
We don't have time
to screw around.
We need to make decisions now.
If I told you the real
stories behind the scenes
about how we managed
to Ebola, how we
managed Zika, how we managed
a lot of these issues--
and there are books
out there like,
And the Band Played
On about HIV.
You will find that we've been
playing games for decades,
and it's very unfortunate.
But some of those games are
important games to play.
You need peer review, right?
You do.
You need to be sure of what
you're dealing with here.
So there's a minimal
tolerance of false alarms.
In our world however,
we embrace false alarms.
We want to be on that bleeding
edge of alert notification.
I am intolerant of people
playing games with information
when we're dealing
with an event that
could cause massive
socioeconomic disruption
or scare the living
heck out of the public.
I want resolution of uncertainty
as fast as we can get it.
And I'm willing to
take false positives.
Now that's a very different
perspective, it really is.
And a totally
different work culture.
In my world, I was dealing
with the time sensitive issues.
The very bleeding edge of a flip
point where a community is just
humming along in their
activities of daily living
and all of a sudden,
somebody flinches.
So the birth of health security
intelligence really began--
and there have
been various groups
that have looked at this from
intelligence perspectives
since going back as far as
the Spanish flu of 1918.
But they've done it
for various reasons
and with different
purposes in mind.
I actually started my
career trying to forecast
Ebola using satellite imagery.
But my sample size
was really small
and I was having a hard
time publishing the paper.
Because you want a robust
sample size, right?
You want to meet certain
criteria for publication.
We just couldn't
get it out there.
But I needed to get it out
there because I needed people
to test the hypothesis.
Right?
So this is in the late
1990s, before we had bioRxiv
and some of these
other systems to enable
us to share that information.
But when I walked around
our country trying
to find the one agency that
actually has a watch cell that
actually does,
indeed, do nothing
but watch the entire
planet for bad things.
I couldn't find it.
And I say, I went everywhere.
I even went to the
department of transportation
in desperateness.
Why don't we have a National
Weather Service equivalent
for infectious disease?
I am angry after 25 years
we still don't have it.
So I tried to convince people.
What would it take for us
to have one for the world?
West Nile virus was the
beginning of that discourse.
And I'm here to tell you that
West Nile unfortunately, sadly
did not kill enough people.
You have to kill people.
You have to kill Americans.
You've got to do
it fast, and you've
got to do it in a nice
cluster, and you've
got to get a good sample size.
And you've got to
kill the young,
and you've got to kill
working age adults.
Think about it, what's
it going to take
to get political willpower
to back something like that?
What ultimately got us
started was actually SARS.
Where our team actually looked
at some of these signatures
that were actually reported
in publicly available
Chinese media, and realized
that we actually missed plenty
of heads up warning for months.
Months.
OK, I'm sorry the Chinese
actually didn't really
hide a lot.
There was a lot of information.
Now, why did we miss it?
Well, there's some pretty ugly
questions to be asked there,
yes?
4 1/2 months is what I'm talking
about in terms of the time
delta.
We've had alleged
bioweapon events, including
one that I recently published
on the largest anthrax
epidemic documented
in modern history
during that counterinsurgency
in Rhodesia in the late 1970s.
Interesting events that
shouldn't have gone unnoticed,
that shouldn't have
gone unreported.
Why aren't there
many publications
about these events?
Lab accidents, we've
had lab accidents, yes.
Many of which have
not been reported.
I think Kevins provided
us with ample hints
of there is research going
on around this world.
Are we aware of who's
doing what, where?
Genetic manipulation
of H5N1 virus
to get it to transmit
more efficiently
is my popular favorite.
Do we know if they've
had a lab accident?
What happens if they
do have a lab accident?
Do we have vaccine ready
on standby in case they do?
Will it be able to be
deployed fast enough?
Unfortunately, these
are the questions
that we're stuck
with in my world.
HIV/AIDS, took us a long
time to figure that one out.
Venezuelan equine
encephalitis, that's
an agent that is
mosquito transmitted very
similar to some of the other
agents we've discussed today,
causes pediatric encephalitis.
We had a huge epizootic
in Venezuela for which
we didn't receive warning.
And there was a
convergence of the peak
of the epidemic with the peak
of direct nonstop air traffic
to Dade County, Florida.
West Nile, well, that's
been robustly discussed
by Tracy McNamara who's the
Bronx Zoo veterinarian who
helped raise the alarm on that.
And all of the
challenges she faced
trying to get people to pay
attention to what's going on.
And if you really
talk to Tracy, you'll
find out that later, she had a
really hard time getting a job.
She is a national
hero in my opinion,
she should have gotten a medal.
SARS, we already talked about.
MERS, when was the first time
MERS was really detected?
Wasn't in the kingdom
of Saudi Arabia.
It was in Jordan.
It too, was blatantly
apparent to any analyst who
was monitoring in the native
vernacular, or Arabic media,
where they talked about an
unusual, atypical, fatal
illness killing ICU
health care workers.
Cholera, Haiti.
I was asked not to
reveal my suspicion
that the UN Mirabi base was the
source of the cholera disaster.
My response to that
was, if we believe
the UN to be the epitome of
the world, then act like it.
It's called corporate
responsibility.
It was an accident,
do not deny it.
Ebola.
How long was it on the
ground before we were finally
able to mount a response?
chikungunya, zika.
This is a pattern it's
been going on for decades.
So, targeting.
So in our world we really are
focused on a subset of disease,
the things that move very
quickly are locally unfamiliar.
This speaks to diagnostics,
availability of infrastructure
on the ground.
It has to be clinically
significant, right?
Can't be a mild disease.
Ideally, it kills.
Ideally, it maims.
Ideally, it marks the
individual so that any layperson
can see what's going on.
You have to affect
a certain segment
of the population, as
I've hinted at before:
children, working age adults.
If it affects the elderly,
unfortunately that gets buried.
People don't talk about
illnesses in the elderly,
worldwide, like they do
with working age adults.
Problems with access
to diagnostics
and countermeasures.
So if we don't have a vaccine,
that's concerning to us.
If you don't have an
effective antibiotic.
Efficient transmission
is a big one, right?
And that has to do
with the dynamics.
Do we have herd immunity
on the ground or not?
The data focus.
We use global media.
Now, I'm going to tell you
flat out, no company on Earth
has a full grasp of the
entire global output of media.
If you think ProMed
does it, guess again.
If you think Google
OK, Rupert Murdoch has played
actually quite a strong role
in actually restricting our
access to media over time,
so you have to pay
for everything now.
So now the costs have increased.
We had to monitor, just
to give you an idea,
we had 50 full-time analysts
who spoke 50 languages
as their primary language.
That's what it took to get at
the barest tip of this iceberg.
We had 5,000 live
events on the radar
a day that we had
to keep an eye on.
5,000 that were threated.
And you've got to pick which
one of those 5,000 events
that you're actually
going to pick up the phone
and put your career on the
line and call somebody about.
Tough work.
And human networks.
And really what
you're looking at
is you're tipping and
queuing, tipping and queuing.
And it's a constant dialogue,
it's a constant conversation.
And you're having these
conversations with researchers,
with physicians, with
journalists, with anyone
who is close to the
action to try to say, hey,
is this something
or is this nothing?
At a time when we have
no epidemiological data.
At a time when we might not
have any diagnostic information
at all other than
people are dying.
Or there's a report that people
panic evacuated a village.
The bias, of course,
when you're dealing
with data of any kind in
the electronic environment
is, of course, where
is there infrastructure
to support that data?
So we knew very well that it
tends to follow this city light
map, which should make sense.
It's where you have
electricity, right?
So in this analysis and
dissemination piece,
we have used forecasting
tools for decades.
So if anybody tells you that
we cannot forecast infectious
disease, I'm here to tell you
that's just a blatant lie.
It ain't true.
We do.
We have been for a long time.
How do we use it?
We use it to set the hypothesis
when we're tracking something
in the real time space.
We say, OK, I expect
to see that we're
about to enter cholera season.
I'm also forecasting the
entire social response
pattern in that community.
I know what they're going to do.
What countermeasures
they're going
to deploy, how they talk
about it in the media,
whether or not there's social
anxiety, whether or not
the hospital gets overwhelmed.
We have all that information
and we know what to expect.
So therefore, if you
know what to expect,
you can recognize deviations.
And you can recognize
when, uh-oh, that train
seems to be coming
off the rails here.
What's going on?
Signal processing, I've
kind of hinted to that.
That's the recognition of an
anomalous signature pattern,
or an anomalous pattern that's
appearing in the system.
There's a myriad of
different ways to do that.
We have pattern libraries.
So there's an Ebola signature.
One of our speakers
from the morning
was talking about the
Nigerian experience.
That signature
looked like a country
that is well adapted to
handling those kinds of issues.
Whereas the signature of
a country that has never
encountered Ebola before
with no infrastructure it,
to us, looks like a heart
attack, wild fluctuations
of indicators.
Sensitization, desensitization
of human networks.
We will actually ramp up entire
global networks of people
to watch for something, and
then tamp them down again.
Now, the tamping down is
a really important piece
that people really
don't appreciate.
I spend, actually, 98% of my
time home calming people down.
Indication warning
methodology is really
what we're talking about
here, which is a Cold War
intelligence
analytic methodology
and it's available
for you to review
in the public literature.
Now, here's an example.
So we manage the Japan
Medical Intelligence Center.
These are actual
forecasts for legionella,
carbapenum-resistant
gram negatives, which
is a gram negative
bacteria that is
resistant to one of our end of
line categories of antibiotics.
I'm, also, side note, very much
into anti-microbial resistance
tracking.
And EHEC, which is a
disease we often see--
or, not often,
thank god not often,
a disease we occasionally
see in pediatrics.
So the point here is, I
have a different demand
for forecasting.
I just want to know if we're
about to hit the season or not
across dozens of diseases,
down to the prefecture level,
down to the community level.
And we have this information
across multiple countries.
It does exist.
Here's for Nevada.
And on the left
side here, this is
an example of an unusual
fall outbreak of H3N2.
That's a seasonal
influenza and we
were able to recognize it
very quickly because we had
the baselines for influenza.
So a lot of this
information is very
reminiscent of what already
happens in epidemiology.
We know what the
seasons are, right?
We do build
statistical baselines.
The question is, so what?
How do you interface
with this information?
How do you communicate
with people?
And how do you blend it with
your awareness of what's
happening in the community?
And in this case on the
left, what happened was
physicians were recommending
the influenza vaccine
to older adults in December
because of waning immunity.
The vaccine protective
period does not
last as long in older adults.
And so rightfully so
our community said,
well, just wait until
December to get that vaccine.
Well, we had four
fatalities due to type
A influenza by
mid-October that year.
And it was actually
a warning failure.
And I got in a world of trouble
with my local public health
people for pointing that out.
RSV, you see that peak
there, that red line
goes above our forecast band.
That's a point where I
actually picked up the phone
and called our
pediatric intensive care
unit to make sure that our
soul PICU in the county
wasn't getting overwhelmed.
Are they calling up
backup ventilators,
this kind of thing.
So it's very important to kind
of put your data in context
with your infrastructure.
What's happening?
Are we able to respond?
Attribution.
So this is the
actual email that I
sent to 1,000 people
on the ground in Haiti
about our suspicions
about the Mirabi base.
I don't expect you to
be able to read it.
But the point here is
that this was basically
the culmination of this kind of
messy world of data gathering
and human conversation.
This was the tip where
we knew that we weren't
dealing with endemic
Haitian cholera
as some people were arguing.
That we were actually dealing
with an imported virgin soil
epidemic of Nepalese cholera,
whole different animal.
And had national security
implications from the Haitian
government point of view.
Signal recognition.
So how did we provide
the tip off on swine flu?
Well, that was
open source media.
Unfortunately for us, we
ran into some crossed wires
with CDC who didn't
want to tell the press
and acknowledge that we had
given them this information.
We lost a $10 million
company over this.
And I sent another
50 analysts home.
Challenges.
Well, as I've hinted,
this is a direct challenge
to established bureaucracies.
There are many
disagreements regarding
what is considered
an alert priority.
I've spent my career playing
Cassandra, the Greek tragedy
of being cursed with
the ability of forecast
and no one will listen to you.
Failure by bureaucracies
to use the intelligence.
I've seen this over, and
over, and over again.
I'm tired of seeing it.
Lack of understanding what
to do with the information.
Well, OK, that's an
important challenge, right?
That perhaps I can help with.
Information control.
If you think that people
don't control information,
you're not living in reality.
Everyone does it.
And they do it in
my own locality.
OK, I see hospitals hiding
information all the time,
about drug resistance
for instance.
And of course,
denial and deception.
The funny thing is, if you ask
anyone in the national security
committee they will put
that last bullet first.
Saying, well, the state actor
is suppressing information.
The hardest time I've
had getting information
has nothing to do
with that, it has
to do with my own local folks.
It's the pogo cartoon, right?
Who's the real enemy here?
Challenges.
Academic and
operations disconnect.
So it's very hard
to have somebody
like me sit in on a
collaborative research group
to give them guidance
and say, look, this
is what's really important.
If you go down this road,
honestly, great paper.
You get your PhD thesis but we
won't be able to put it to use,
and there are all kinds
of reasons for that.
There's an operations/policy
disconnect.
I hate this.
This is the thing that
actually is driving me squarely
into insanity.
We keep seeing policy
drafted out of Washington
and it's quite clear that the
people who drafted the policy
have never done
this work before.
Transparent accountability.
I've just hinted at multiple
intelligence failures.
When was the last time we had
an open congressional session
where we sort of reviewed
who knew what, when,
and why didn't you
share that information?
Time for that to
change, I think.
Substantial inability to provide
balanced risk assessment.
So this hints at our culture's
tendency to hype things.
I do think that we hype things.
I know I've got 30 seconds, so
let's rip through this fast.
Live example.
There has been a
proclamation that we're
going to be hit with a
severe influenza season.
Some of you may have seen this.
And it came out of Australia.
Australian media talking
about the worst flu
outbreak on record in 2017.
Worst on record in 2017.
In general, we get our season
what the southern hemisphere
in the season
immediately preceding us.
So this is Tony
Fauchi saying this.
Now, if he understood,
perhaps, what
this looks like from
our perspective,
I wouldn't have gone that
far out with that comment.
I would have maybe
hesitated to have said that,
because it's not actually
very much a guarantee at all
that we're going
to see what they
see in the southern hemisphere.
But it hit CNN.
Flu jab warning.
NHS, National Health Service
of the United Kingdom,
warns of major outbreak.
Getting vaccinated could
be life threatening.
This is the United Kingdom.
So there's a spread of a meme.
British flu deaths may rise in
the worst epidemic in 50 years
after Australian
strain outbreak.
And now, the media
is creative, they're
going to swap that
virus out and say
it's due to H2N2 which was
a pandemic strain not seen
since 1957.
Creative.
I've got to hand it to them.
Again, current
influenza season being
worst on record and
evidence that the elderly
are particularly--
so Sanofi Pasteur
chiming in now to take
profitability options here.
And now the Canadians
are picking up on this.
Now Canada is all
lit up thinking
they are about to get
hit with a pandemic.
This is all happening
right now, by the way.
- In the interest of time--
- Yeah, it's going
to be two slides.
So, admissions to
sentinel hospitals.
This is the actual
report from Australia
that started this
entire train of events.
Note the underlined comment.
And not necessarily
reflecting an increase
in severity infection.
So what has happened
here is that they're
diagnosing more cases, it is
not necessarily more severe.
But that don't let
that stop the media.
And then finally,
we see somebody
rational after months
of this spreading
across multiple
countries this meme.
Finally somebody
in Canada decides
to say, now, wait a minute,
maybe we're overblowing this.
And then last but not
least, what's happening now?
We have perfectly
routine influenza
being documented by CDC.
Now, this may change, of course.
The influenza virus that's
in circulation right
now is covered by our
current vaccine, so much ado
about, perhaps nothing.
So I'll close with that.
With the point that it would
be nice to have a little bit
of balance in the discourse.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you.
Thank you, Jim.
So we can debate the how
good forecasts are all day,
but we can do that later maybe.
Next speaker is Jess Metcalf.
She is an assistant
professor at Princeton.
You can read her
bio in your book.
And she's going
to talk about how
we can move national control
programs forward using modeling
and new technologies.
- Hi.
So it's a great
pleasure to be here.
I'm going to talk about
how we can actually
connect some of
these new, exciting
and to use the term
big data streams,
to public health questions.
And I'm going to focus my
discussion around measles.
So measles is a directly
transmitted, completely
immunizing infection.
So that means for someone
to give someone else measles
they have to be in proximity.
And once you've had measles,
you'll never have it again.
So it has a very
simple life cycle.
Individuals tend to
be born susceptible.
They then become
infected, and then recover
and are protected for life.
We have a safe, inexpensive, and
completely immunizing vaccine.
And since the case
fatality rate for measles
can be extremely high, as high
as 20% in low resource settings
and in catastrophes, and because
the consequences of measles
can be so bad,
measles vaccination
has been referred to as a
best buy in public health.
Following successful eradication
of smallpox and polio,
the Pan American
Health Organization
decided to target measles
elimination in 1994.
A combination of
routine vaccination
with large campaigns designed
to both interrupt transmission
and maintain high
population immunity
meant that this was
achieved within a decade.
It was a very
remarkable success.
In the rest of the
world, the situation
was not so successful.
So the x-axis on all
these graphs is time
and the y-axis is
numbers of cases.
And you can see that
red line is Paho.
Afro is the African WHO region.
And WPR is the West
Pacific region.
They're falling
much more slowly.
Although there were substantial
gains at the beginning,
progress has been interrupted.
And we know why, partly.
There is considerable inequity
in vaccination coverage
across the globe.
The yellow countries on
this plot in around 2011
had coverage of less than 80%.
Of course, these
national statistics
also conceal a lot of
important heterogeneity.
And even in countries that
seem to be doing really well,
there have been large,
unexpected outbreaks.
So this is an example
of one in Malawi
that had a well-performing
system and very
few cases for about a
decade, and then experienced
this large late age
outbreak in 2010.
And it made sense.
We know why that happens.
Vaccination coverage was
good, but not perfect.
So every year, a certain
number of children
were not being immunized
and they were also
escaping infection because
we had successfully
reduced transmission.
And that meant that
when the infection came,
there was this large outbreak.
We used to think that measles
was so transmissible-- it
is so transmissible--
that there was
no point trying to intervene
once the epidemic could taken
off.
We know through
carefully modeling now
that that's not the case.
Outbreak reactive vaccination
is now indicated by WHO.
And of course, it's
even better if you could
have anticipated this outbreak.
If two months, or three months
before the measles outbreak
had kicked off in
Malawi you'd been
able to reach the
population and vaccinate it,
you could have averted many,
many cases, potentially.
And thus, deaths and
thus the morbidity.
But what would we
need to do that?
We need two pieces to
do that successfully.
And the first is that
we need to understand
the landscape of immunity.
We need to know who's protected
from infection and who isn't.
In this particular example,
the person in red is infected
and I've set this up with R0.
So a number of new
infections of around two.
So it infects two other
people, but there's
a third person who's immune.
And as it progresses and
as the pathogen progresses,
more of the population
is protected.
If we vaccinate
effectively, everybody
should have that little
blue shield on them
and the pathogen should
not be able to spread.
To understand the
landscape for immunity,
we therefore need to understand
both the scale of heterogeneity
in local demographics, because
the source of new susceptible
individuals is births, but
also, the history of vaccination
and infection.
There's another
piece that we need,
and that is that we need to
understand human mobility.
So we need to understand if you
have successfully eliminated
measles in a particular
location but you're not
vaccinating everybody so
susceptibles can build up.
You might still get
away with it for a bit
because the only way measles
is going to arrive in your city
or your district is if someone
with measles turns up there.
So we need to
understand how people
are moving around the
landscape in order
to grapple with understanding
the landscape of immunity
and mobility to predict
when outbreaks would occur.
So what we wanted to do, and
Caroline was part of this work,
was see if we could figure
out retrospectively using
all the tools we had available
could we have got ahead
of an example
historical outbreak.
And the example
outbreak we used was
one that happened in
2010-12 in Pakistan.
So again, x-axis
years, y-axis cases.
So we mustered all the
data we had available.
And first of all, to calibrate
the landscape of immunity
we pulled together the
vaccination coverage surveys
that had been done in
Pakistan over previous years.
And it's quite a luxury having
vaccination coverage surveys
because this doesn't exist
for many of the settings
where measles is a concern.
We put this together with
births and we put this together
with our best guess of what the
history of infection had been.
And this is actually
a reasonable thing
to do because in the
era pre-vaccination
it's reasonable to assume
that everybody got measles.
There's this great quotation,
measles is like love,
everybody gets it.
And it was definitely
true back in the day.
So we built a picture
of what we thought
the landscape of immunity was.
And then to put this
together with human mobility,
we leveraged a source of data
that Caroline really pioneered,
which is using mobile
phone call data
records to capture
how people are
moving across the landscape.
And the way this works
is that every time you
make a call, the
tower that you're
closest to routes that call.
So if we know where
the towers are and we
have a record of the
calls, we can figure out
these large scale
fluxes of population.
And this data comes with
no other information.
We just know where people are
and where they've moved to.
We don't know their age.
We don't know the
vaccination status.
What we have is
fluxes of mobility.
So to evaluate our
ability to predict,
we're also going to need
information on measles itself.
And so we had two
sources of data here.
One was province
scale case reports.
So over the time scale
from September 2012
on the left going forward to
September 2013 on the right,
there were records
of numbers of cases
in each of the provinces of
Pakistan shown by the colors.
So we compiled that data.
It's not perfect, right?
If you're interested
in human mobility,
Pakistan is rather large
and provinces is rather
a large scale to be
thinking about this problem.
So we also pulled in
another source of data.
And this was a different
source of information which
was district levels alert data.
So when local health officials
of a particular district
thought a measles
outbreak was kicking off,
that data was sent up to
the Ministry of Health
and was available to us.
It's not actually instance data.
We don't know the total number
of cases that were there.
They might just have
flagged up that something
was about to happen.
OK, so how am I going to see
if I can predict this data?
Well, what I'm going
to do is build a model
of what Pakistan looks like.
And this is a very crude
cartoon, obviously,
for feasibility.
If every one of the points
is a different district, what
the mobile phone data
gives me is a sense
of the fluxes of
individuals between all
these different points.
So there might be
strong connections
between some districts
and weaker connections
between others.
For every one of these districts
I also have a sense of what
proportion of the population
is immune to measles and what
isn't.
And that's going to matter
for the pathogen spread.
So I have my sense of how
the world works based on all
the big data that I have.
And then what I'm going to
do is initiate an outbreak
in the setting where I know that
the outbreak kicked off based
on the district alert data.
And I'm going to
run a simulation.
And this works essentially by
saying, the outbreak begins.
It might have moved,
you know, if this
was the district that
was most connected it
might have moved here next.
The outbreak continues in
the two first districts.
It might move to a
third, and so on.
So over time, I'm going to
have a full simulation of what
the outbreak looked
like in every one
of the districts of Pakistan.
And importantly, every
time I rerun this you
might get a slightly
different picture
because I'm assuming that
chance is going to play a role.
That some routes are going
to be fairly similarly
important at different
times, and so we're
flipping a coin to figure
out which one predominates.
So every simulation might end up
looking a little bit different.
But overall, they
look a bit like this.
So this is simulated
trajectories
across all districts in Pakistan
based on the mobile phone
data and the landscape
of immunity data.
The x-axis is time in by
weeks over the time course
we were focused on.
And the y-axis is the
number of cases we obtained.
So we need a way to
evaluate whether this
is any good or not, obviously.
And so for that, we go back
to our original district alert
data.
The province level data is just
too coarse to do much with.
And we chose to focus
on the question of,
could we anticipate,
could we predict
how many districts would
occur after a certain point
in the future?
Because in that case,
we could rush out there.
We could start
preparing campaigns,
we could maybe get
ahead of the wave
and that would be a considerable
public health benefit.
So on this plot, what we have is
time and by weeks on the x-axis
into the future.
And on the y-axis is the
proportion of districts
that we accurately predict to
have happened after the time
point on the x-axis.
So at the start of the outbreak,
100% of districts happening
in the future, we do quite well.
That's not too impressive.
And then the
proportion predicted
to happen in the
future falls off.
And by about 10 by week,
so about five months,
we're doing as well
as a coin flip.
So we're doing 50%.
And after that, our
predictions get even worse.
Because we have a
model, and the model
is less good than just saying,
stuff might happen by chance.
So, is it helpful?
It's been estimated
during measles outbreaks
in Malawi that it takes about
two to three months to get
a campaign up and running.
So we're buying a
little bit of time
there, potentially
on that scale.
But we're not doing great.
It's important to think about
why we aren't doing great.
And in this context, it's
important to remember
that every one of
our data sources
has uncertainties in it.
So the vaccination data might
have reporting biases in it.
We might only be
finding the children
to report on coverage
who had been vaccinated
because the ones who aren't
vaccinated, by definition,
are probably hard to find.
We might have a large
population, therefore,
of missed children.
So our vaccination
coverage estimates
will be really optimistic.
Mobility data, mobile phone
data is really amazing
and gives you this
incredible window
into how people are moving
around the landscape.
We don't know if it's
relevant to children.
We don't know if it's relevant
to transmission from one
individual to the next.
There's a quite specific biology
underlying measles transmission
and these big fluxes
might not capture it.
And then the case data.
It's true everywhere in the
world, even and outbreak
in Holland in 2007
it was estimated
that 10% of measles
cases were reported.
Nobody reported measles cases.
So that data is
also fairly erratic.
And I think this
comes back to a thread
that Caroline alluded
to in the beginning.
To make any progress
around really leveraging
these unique and powerful
novel sources of information
requires really strengthening
existing sources of information
and really basic epidemiology,
case reports, vaccination
coverage.
No one ever seems to write down
what fraction of the population
they vaccinated.
Possibly because they have
more important things to do,
like vaccinate children,
but it would be helpful.
So one of the things
we've been thinking about
as we move forwards
in this space
is I told you I need two pieces
to really try and predict
where and when an outbreak
is going to happen.
And even for measles,
which is perhaps
one of the world's simplest and
best understood of pathogens,
it's really hard.
And we ended up thinking
about, is there another way?
Is there another
approach we could
take to refining
our understanding
of the landscape of immunity?
And really, we
started from the fact
that this is the central
process in epidemiology.
I told you, individuals
start off susceptible,
that's the S. They become
infected if they encounter
an infected person.
That's the I. And
then they recover.
And just about every
piece of modeling
around infectious
diseases has some variant
of this basic schematic in it.
Yet all we ever see when
we're trying to build
these forecasts is cases.
The susceptibles and the
recovereds are invisible to us.
And we can infer who's
susceptible and who isn't.
That's what I did here.
I pulled together information on
births and vaccinations to try
and figure out who could
have got the infection,
who was protected,
and who wasn't.
And in measles--
this is an example
of pre-vaccination measles
in England and Wales.
It's very straightforward.
The number of
susceptibles in two weeks
time is the number
of susceptibles now
plus new births minus
whoever got infected.
So you just iterate it forwards
and you have your trajectory
of susceptibles.
Almost everywhere in the world
would be a lot like Pakistan
where the case data was shaky,
the vaccination coverage data
was shaky.
In fact, everywhere
now has measles vaccine
so you have to account for it.
But it turns out that there is
potentially another approach
to getting at that.
And that is that
serology can directly
measure susceptibility.
So this is where if I were
to go out into the audience
and take your blood, which
would be very strange,
I could evaluate whether you had
been vaccinated against measles
or not.
And I'm guessing that
everybody in this audience
has an antibody titer that
is protective to measles.
In my case, it's actually
because I was infected.
But we can discuss
that with my mother.
And you can do much more nuanced
really interesting things.
So for example, I could
evaluate whether you'd
been exposed to
particular flu strains,
like Hong Kong 68 or Bangkok 71.
Which tells me whether you were
in a part of the world that
was connected to the
rest of the globe
during these global pandemics.
So it's an incredible window
onto the past of populations.
And it's an incredible window
into predicting the future,
and the likely
burden of infections.
It allows us to project.
It gives us a direct measure
of this landscape of immunity.
And so with colleagues,
one of the things
we're very excited
about moving forwards
in considering big
data and the world
of contagion and
epidemics is developing
a global immunological
observatory.
And our logic here is that
if you think about weather
forecasting, we have
buoys distributed
all over the seas of the
world to measure sea surface
temperature to strengthen our
prediction of global climate.
And yet we have
nothing equivalent
for infectious diseases.
But all of our blood is
this unbelievable sensor
of all the things
we've been exposed to,
all the things we've
been infected by.
And the technology is
ramping up to a stage
where you need smaller
and smaller samples
and you can get more
and more resolution
across even more pathogens.
It would give you the
prospects of anticipating
hidden epidemics or
at least understanding
when they were occurring long
before perhaps cases blipped up
on the radio.
You might be thinking,
well, that's not,
I mean, how are we
going to store that?
What are the ethics of it?
And it's absolutely true.
There's a huge amount of
both ethical and logistical
considerations that
have to come through.
But I think the prospects
are such that there are so
many ways in which you could
use convenience samples,
if you think about blood banks.
We could be using
blood banks to think
about what the world's kind of
epidemiological and contagion
risks are.
There are all sorts
of carefully designed
nationally
representative surveys
that could add a
biological sample to it.
And there's even
the prospect of not
needing to use blood because
it's really hard to get blood,
but using saliva for
some of these techniques
with many of the new
technological innovations,
many of which are actually
happening at Harvard
that would allow us to do this.
So that's all I have.
And I did all of this with
Caroline, Andy Tatem, and other
[INAUDIBLE].
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you, Jess.
So our final speaker for today's
panel is going to move from--
we've been to global threats,
and national vaccination
programs, and serology.
Ami Bhatt from Stanford
is going to talk
now about a more personal scale,
thinking about the microbiome
and how our
bacterial communities
and viral communities interact
to create susceptibility
to disease.
And what it can teach us about
the development of new drugs
and approaches to
make people healthy.
- All right, so
thank you very much.
What a pleasure to be
a part of this event
and to be a part of this panel.
So I'm going to speak
for the microbes today.
And I'm going to think
about epidemics with you
all through the lens
of the microbiome.
And whether we like it or
not, a huge wave of data
are coming at us and we're
just at the beginning
of trying to build tools to
understand these microbes,
to enumerate these microbes, and
to figure out how they change
over time and space.
So I'm going to start out
by helping you get to know
your trillions of neighbors.
I'll try to convince you
that context matters.
And I'll try to give you a sense
of the perils of a simplified
microbiome.
I'll scare you a little bit.
Our microbiome are under siege.
And I'll remind you that
while we talk about pathogens
and microorganisms as though
they're stagnant organisms,
they're alive and
they're changing.
I'll end by giving you
a very simple example
of microbial evolution
on a clinical time scale.
So number one, getting to know
your trillions of neighbors.
We are one, but we are many.
There are about 10 to 100
trillion microbes within each
and every one of us.
They make up about 3%
of our human body mass.
We have 1 to 10 times as many
microbes as we do human cells.
There are 10 to 100 times
many microbial genes
as there are human genes.
And of course, as you all
know, the largest number
of microbes that we have
are in our GI tract.
Over the course
of today's seminar
we've heard a lot about
how microbes can be bad.
And I'm not here to disagree.
But sometimes they can
be good, or neutral.
We know that we
exist or co-exist
with these trillions
of microorganisms
and that they are inexplicably
intertwined with ourselves.
And so while many of us
will look at this picture
and see the host or the
faces, when I look at this,
I see the microbes.
And what I understand is
that if the microbes change,
well, perhaps we will as well.
And so part of what motivates
me as a physician scientist
is trying to understand
this interface so that we
can manipulate host health
through manipulation
of the microbiota.
So I alluded to the fact that
microorganisms can be good.
And to make this point, I'll
actually pull an example
from the animal kingdom.
I like elephants, which is
part of why I have this picture
here.
But it turns out that this
is also an excellent example
of why microorganisms are good.
So elephants are one
of many organisms
that actually eat poop.
They don't eat poop
throughout their lifetime,
they only do it when
they're children.
And if babies do not eat stool
from adults from the herd,
they actually have
a runting problem,
which means that they
don't grow properly.
The microorganisms that they
acquire through adult feces
actually help them
to extract energy
from their food optimally.
So this is an
excellent example I
think from the natural world
about microbial good guys.
When we think about microbiome
sciences and the little tidbits
that I gave you earlier, a
lot of how we've enumerated
understood the microbiome
has relied upon techniques
for enumeration.
And while light
microscopy was probably
the first method
that was successfully
applied to enumerate
microorganisms
that were visible, there
are other methods as well.
And a vast majority
of these methods
now rely upon DNA
or RNA sequencing.
And so Professor
Happi earlier today
talked about beautiful work
using DNA and RNA sequencing
to enumerate microorganisms,
in that case viruses,
and to understand not
only whether or not
they exist within a human,
but how they change over time.
And so the fundamental
basis of most
of the experiments
that I'll describe
is taking a sample,
usually a mixed sample,
sequencing it, generating these
lists of A's, and T's, and G's,
and C's, and then
trying to infer
from that information what
microorganisms are present.
Put more simplistically,
my job is to collect stool,
to extract nucleic acids, and
to ask simple questions like,
who's there?
What are they doing?
And what do they make?
In order to do so,
obviously we're
generating gigabytes and
now terabytes of data.
And so we require high
throughput computational
pipelines to actually
achieve this.
So next, we're going
to talk about context.
And I'm going to try to convince
you that context matters,
and that having a
simplified microbiome
comes with its problems.
So for that, I was really happy
to see that I had this orange.
I got this orange for my lunch.
I'll eat it at the break.
You know, this is an orange.
This is probably not
very scary to any of you.
I presume you do not
find it threatening.
You probably also do not
find this orange threatening.
I think almost all of
you have seen this movie.
This is from The Godfather.
For those of you who haven't
seen The Godfather, you should.
These are an excellent
series of movies.
But on a more serious
note, in The Godfather
you may notice that every time
there is an orange in a scene,
it actually portends bad things.
And usually the person
engaged with the orange dies.
Sorry, spoiler alert.
So, you know, these
oranges, not so bad.
Those oranges, quite worrisome.
And so an orange, is not an
orange, is not an orange.
Likewise, microbes
are not always
pathogenic in all circumstances.
And so the context
in which you view
those microbes and the context
in which they exist actually
strongly affects their function.
So we'll turn now to the perils
of the simplified microbiome
and think about
context in that way.
So here are two microbiomes.
The one on the left is
a complex microbiome.
This is what, for example
your stool microbial
might look like.
The one on the right is,
obviously, very simplified.
All you see is these Good
and Plenty looking rods.
It turns out this exists
in clinical medicine.
So an example of how this
exists in clinical medicine
is in the setting of C. diff.
Many of you have heard of C.
diff, clostridium difficile.
Now actually, it's called
pepto clostridium difficile.
Is an organism that
is an opportunist.
And typically, it exists,
colonizes many healthy people.
We have a few hundred people
in here, about 5% of us
are colonized with C. diff.
It doesn't cause any problems.
However, in the setting of
a simplified microbiomes
when you don't have a healthy
context, it causes disease.
So this is an example
of an opportunist
that is pathogenic only
in a given context.
And so while we can look at
pathogens, and infectious,
disease, and epidemics
and contagions
through the lens
of the pathogen,
we can also think about
it from the standpoint
of those who are susceptible,
as just pointed out.
Now, many of you know of the
most successful treatments
for C. diff is actually
not antibiotics,
but fecal microbiota
transplantation.
This happens to be my
favorite picture of FMT which
shows you connecting two
people's colons, which
we obviously do not do.
Over on the right
this is like probably
not right after lunch
picture, but this
is an example of a crapsule.
This is--
[LAUGHTER]
This is just from across
the river over at MGH,
A colleague of
mine, Libby Hohmann,
generates these capsules.
And actually, if you take
15 of those pills one day,
15 pills the next
day you can actually
have a very high rate of
cure of your C. difficile.
In part, because
what you're doing is
you're giving a healthy
microbiome context back
to an individual who has
a simplified microbiome.
How cool is that?
Now, of course, our
microbes are under siege.
I'm worried about them.
I know you guys did
a good job of going
and having lunch and taking
care of your microbes.
But many have argued
that industrialization
increases exposure to agents
that change our microbiome.
So when you reflect upon
your daily life, what
are the things that
we're doing that might
simplify our microbiome?
Well, if we look at humans
throughout evolutionary time,
early on in the
hunter gatherer days
the main thing that affected
our microbiome was our diet.
Our diet, and occasional
exposure to pathogens that
caused terrible
diarrhea and essentially
kind of a clean out.
As we went to a more
agricultural sort of setting,
diet again was a major effector.
As we became more and
more industrialized,
heavy metals and
arsenic introduced
were introduced into
our environment.
And finally, in the modern day
adding onto those heavy metals
and arsenic, we also
had broad scale exposure
to antiseptics and antibiotics.
So by a show of
hands, how many of you
think you might have been
exposed to antibiotics today?
I'm going to argue
that it's everyone.
So this compound over on
the left is triclosan.
Triclosan is a
common antiseptic.
It actually was originally
developed in the 1960s
as a surgical anesthetic.
It's a very simple molecule.
And for those of you
who aren't chemists,
anytime you see a simple
molecule you can look
smart at a cocktail
party by saying,
I bet somebody synthesized that.
Because when nature
synthesizes molecules
they're awfully complex.
So this is a synthesized
antimicrobial.
It's very broad spectrum.
And it's in thousands
of consumer products.
Now, you may know
that the FDA banned
triclosan and several
related compounds in 2016.
That ban just went into effect.
So you won't see
anti-microbial hand soaps
on your shelves for example.
Now, while it was banned
in certain household wash
products, it's still
present in lots of things.
And I would guess that
even the chairs that we're
sitting on today have
antimicrobials that
are impregnated into the cloth.
So Jessica Roboto, a talented
graduate student in my lab,
decided to study this.
And we collaborated
with an epidemiologist
named Julie
Parsonnet at Stanford
to evaluate the
impacts of triclosan
on a cohort of mothers
and their babies.
To make a long story short,
this is a complicated graph.
But suffice it to say
that each dot represents
a bacterial taxon.
So a community of similar
types of microbes.
If you have dots to the
right of the center line,
these are microbes that
are enriched in households
exposed to triclosan.
If you see a dot
on the left, those
are microbes that are
enriched in households
exposed to the control agents.
And what you can see
is in these adults
they happen to be mothers.
Over the course of time
we see an enrichment
of these blue dots on the
right side of the graph.
Which means these are organisms
that are enriched in households
exposed to triclosan.
Interestingly, in this
experiment what was done
was between two and six
months these households were
randomized to be
exposed to toothpaste
that contain triclosan.
Now, triclosan is not
banned from toothpaste.
So while you won't see it
in antibacterial hand soap,
you can walk down the
street to CVS and buy
this particular toothpaste.
And you can see that this is
actually having a broad effect.
Triclosan is actually
the second most abundant
human-made chemical in
waste water treatment plants
and it abounds in
our groundwater.
So whether we like it or not,
we're exposed to this compound.
At least these data suggest
that these compounds
are changing our microbiomes.
You can look up this
in Jessica's paper
that just came out
if you're interested.
And I'm certainly happy to
answer any other questions
you may have on it.
But remember, not only are
our microbiomes under siege
and our microbiomes
are changing,
but our microbes themselves
are alive and changing.
They adapt beautifully
to stressors.
You saw evidence of how
they adapt over time
and acquire mutations in
the setting of outbreaks.
Fundamentally, for
those of you who
are not molecular biologists,
or geneticists in the audience I
though I would just break it
down into two main categories
of ways microbes evolve.
they acquire small mutations.
And so in this case, the
highlighted red letters
are changing to another letter.
Or they can acquire
genes or gene fragments.
And we usually call this
horizontal gene transfer.
And so there are two main
ways bacteria can evolve.
It turns out that we're pretty
good at measuring the way
that organisms
evolve on the left.
So we can measure
those mutations.
Those are pretty easy
using current technologies.
But measuring the thing on
the right has been difficult.
And part of the
reason it's difficult
is because when you have a
horizontal transferred segment,
what it means is that what
you're seeing in this toy
example actually occurs.
Which is you have a repeated
segment, in this case labeled
R, that exists both between
A and D in this case,
as well as between
B and C. Now, this
happens in nature, a
horizontal gene transfer.
An example of where it happens
is in this organism, E. coli.
So I'll just ask you
to raise your hands,
how many when I say like E. coli
feel really good about E. coli?
[LAUGHTER]
It's like a few.
How many of you feel
like kind of bad?
Like we're at a pathogen
conference, so yeah,
many of you feel bad.
And how many of you feel
like it's complicated?
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
Like, I feel like
it's complicated.
You know on one hand, it's
like the most commonly used
bacterial model organism.
Every biology lab
in this country
and probably in the
world uses this.
On the other hand it can cause
enterohemorrhagic E. coli,
which we heard
about earlier today.
Terrible diseases, kill people.
And it turns out that part of
the reason we feel conflicted
is because E. coli can acquire
genes through horizontal gene
transfer that make it very, very
virulent and very dangerous.
So once again, E. coli is
not E. coli, is not E. coli.
So microbes can
certainly evolve.
We know that.
We know microbes can acquire
genes through horizontal gene
transfer.
We've talked about how it's a
little difficult to measure.
But one of the things
that we realize
is that not only can
microbes evolve over
time scales of ten of
years, or hundreds of years,
or millennia.
But they can actually
evolve in real time.
And in order to evaluate
that, our laboratory
studies patients undergoing
bone marrow transplantation.
Bone marrow transplantation is
a potentially curative therapy
for patients with
refractory malignancies.
So cancers like
leukemia and lymphoma.
It's a really
intensive treatment
and it has a very high
complication rate.
But to take you through
the general process.
We have a patient.
We give them a lot of
high dose chemotherapy.
Often we'll also give
them radiation therapy.
This renders them much reduced
in their cancer burden,
but it also means that all of
their rapidly dividing cells,
including the red blood
cells, white blood
cells, and platelets basically
poop out for a period of time.
In order to rescue
them we give them
hematopoietic stem
cells that are
obtained from a healthy donor.
And classically, we obtain
these from the pelvis.
And so that's why it's
called a bone marrow
transplant because we took
the marrow out of the bone.
We give these stem
cells to the recipient
and then we sit around and wait
while a whole new immune system
develops, which is
kind of amazing.
But as you can imagine,
over the course of this time
these patients are
very immunosuppressed.
They were exposed to a lot
of potential antibiotics, et
cetera, to try to both prevent
them from getting infections
and to empirically
treat them when
they get things like fevers.
Because they're exposed to
so many of these compounds
their microbiomes are
for sure under siege.
And this is an example of a
hospital patient at Stanford
who underwent bone
marrow transplant
or hematopoietic
cell transplantation.
These are time points
after transplantation,
so A is before the BMT, and
then B, C, and D are after.
And what you can see
is there microorganisms
basically go away.
This is a stacked bar
histogram relative abundance
on the y-axis.
And you can see that that blue
organism seems to take over.
That blue organism happens
to be bacteroides caccae.
And so two talented
graduate students
in my lab, Alex
Beshara and Eli Moss,
asked this question:
how does this occur?
Why does that organism win?
It must be particularly fit.
Furthermore they said, well,
maybe gene transfer or gene
movement makes this organism
particularly evolutionarily
fit.
And they knew that
measuring this gene transfer
was difficult. Part of
the reason it's difficult
is because if we
simplify that toy
diagram into another
representation what you can see
here is that we can't figure
out whether the right path is
ARC, or ARD, BRD, or BRD.
What they decided to do was to
use a technology that actually
was commercially available
but no computational approach
existed to apply this
technology in microbiomes.
And what this
technology roughly does
is allows you to trace a
trail through the right path.
In so doing, they found
some intriguing results,
which I'll share with you.
I'm going to show
you the genome,
or a piece of the genome
of this organism in blue.
This is what a regular
assembly looks like.
This is 1/6 of the genome.
And what you can see, for
those different time points A,
B, C, and D is you
have a lot of holes.
So it's not contiguous.
When they applied
their new method
they ended up with
these blue bars, so
a much more contiguous genome.
What this allowed them
to do was the following.
They were able to
identify this huge segment
of 60 kilobase pairs of
DNA that actually popped
into the genome
between time point
C and time point D. This
is horizontal gene transfer
in a clinical time scale.
This happened over the course
of days and weeks, not months.
So suddenly, we can
measure genes being
transferred between organisms.
Finally, they were
able to identify
insertion sequences,
or small sequences that
can jump around a genome.
So jumping genes as we
heard about earlier.
This particular jumping gene was
absent in time points A and B
and present in time points C and
D. And these are the results.
You can see I've got time
points B, C, and D here.
The gene ends up in that center,
which is listed as the IS.
And you can see what
happens to the right.
To the right of that
gene what you see is
the genes just
upstream are turned on.
And so whereas in
time point B you
don't see a lot of
expression of that gene.
Those genes are off.
In time point C and D once that
insertion sequence pops in,
suddenly you've flipped a switch
and this antibiotic resistance
gene turns on.
So no genes were
acquired or lost.
This jumping gene
just moved around
and acts as a
random light switch.
So I'll just end
by reminding you,
we have trillions of
neighbors and our microbes
are often good.
Context matters and there
are perils associated
with simplified microbiomes.
They may increase our disease
susceptibility our microbes are
under siege: antiseptics,
antibiotics, industrialization,
and many have argued
simplified diets, low in fiber.
Our microbes are
alive and changing
and they are steadily evolving
through mutations and gene
transfer.
Finally, microbial evolution
can happen on a clinical time
scale.
I showed you evidence of
a shape shifting genome
and antibiotic resistance.
So with that, I'll thank
my lab, thank all of you,
and I'm happy to join the
panel for some questions.
[APPLAUSE]
- OK, thank you to our speakers.
I think this means that we
have six minutes of questioning
between us and then we'll
open it up to the floor.
So those were fantastic
and I think they really
spanned a huge spectrum.
I guess since we just ended
there, Ami I will ask you.
So there's this
huge amount of data
that we can now get
about our microbiome.
It's sometimes hard to make
sense of which bits of it
are epidemiologically
meaningful.
Can you imagine a
scenario where we've
got Jess's serological
bank and we
could have a similar
microbiome bank where
we think about vulnerability?
Because ultimately what
we're trying to do is
think about who's susceptible
to disease of various kinds.
And I wonder if you can comment
on that and on the current work
being done in low
income settings
on this type of microbiome
simplification work.
- Absolutely.
So, excellent questions.
I think fundamentally
our microbiomes
are great reflections of how
we experience our environment.
I'll take your last
question first,
which is this
question of studies
in low and middle
income countries,
and countries that are
currently undergoing
rapid industrialization.
There have been
very limited studies
on the microbiome of
individuals outside
of high income countries,
and indeed, outside
of the US and Western Europe.
And so this is an
area of much need.
We don't have adequate
reference databases
that tell us what the microbiome
of the vast majority of people
in the world look like.
The studies that have
been done have pretty much
been done in small
tribes, often that
are living in subsistence
farming communities,
or in hunter
gatherer communities.
There it's been
demonstrated that at least
at the simplistic taxonomic
level, meaning who's there,
the microbiomes are quite a
bit more complex than our own.
Suggesting that Western
diet, you know the Happy Meal
lifestyle, may be
compromising the complexity
of our microbiomes.
To your point about, will
we ever get to the point
where we can measure
microbiomes and actually
be able to predict
disease susceptibility?
I think we can
absolutely get there.
I think we need to do two things
to achieve that, in addition
to collecting data from
countries outside of those
where our data are
overrepresented.
One is collecting very high
quality clinical phenotype
data.
So whenever we collect
someone's stool sample,
it's absolutely critical
that we collect information
about, for example,
serology, disease history,
migration, lifestyle.
Secondarily, I think
we need to be committed
to measuring what matters.
And in our field we've been
very reliant upon measuring
taxonomy, meaning who's there,
which genus, which species.
As I showed you, these
genomes can evolve.
And so maybe we
need to think more
about measuring elements of
the microbiota that actually
lead to functions, and
measuring what matters.
Maybe we need to measure
what these microbes make
or how they're
changing over time.
- Right.
Thank you.
Or think about antimicrobial
resistance plasmids and things
like this.
So Jess, I'll move to you.
And also, you guys are welcome
to ask each other questions.
But I was thinking about
your serology bank.
We think about surveillance
for emerging epidemics
and zoonosis, and
there are many who
advocate that we should be
going out and sampling macaques
and the wildlife populations.
Is there a way to use serology
data to try and understand
vulnerability to
emerging pathogens
that we have not yet seen?
Do you think that's reasonable?
Or you think it's
limited to things
that we already understand?
- I think that it's
challenging to look
for what you don't know.
But I do think that
once an emergence is
suspected that's where
the power of serology
might come into play.
Because quite often
many of the pathogens--
we heard a lot about
this this morning.
Many pathogens can have
asymptomatic infections
and so you might have
no idea of the scope,
particularly given uncertainty
in reporting systems.
But if you happen to have a
blood bank in northern Brazil
or other locations where
you suspected circulation,
you would have a
way to ground truth
that the way to understand
what might be going on.
- Yeah, and for Ebola too.
- And for Ebola too.
I think there's a lot of
interesting questions about how
whether our evolutionary ecology
theory could actually take us
towards thinking a little
bit more about what
would emerge where, but I think
that's at a very early stage
in the science still.
- Thank you.
And then I'll ask a question
of Jim that's maybe different.
But I think a lot
of the data sources
that you talked about are
often in the private sphere,
and corporations
don't own the data
and are differentially regulated
or have different incentives.
What do you think the
role of corporations
is as we move towards
preparing for a pandemic?
- Well, that's a
loaded question.
I did disclose
here, and again this
is the first time I've
ever said this publicly,
but we lost a $10
million company doing
the right thing for the world.
What incentive does
anyone have when
you have-- and this has
been mentioned before,
by other speakers.
What incentive do we have to
share information when you
face that kind of a penalty?
You blow your market.
If I make the information
available for free,
and part of what killed the
company is that we actually
released the output
of two operations
centers online on Twitter.
After we notified CDC I
told the operative, I said,
listen I'm going to
give you 24 hours
to get this out there
to the American public
before we go live with
everything we've got.
And we did.
What it did it was
it blew out market
because you devalue the product
OK, so there was also questions
asked earlier this morning
about vaccine.
What's the status
of the vaccine?
Well, if you've noticed, we
keep getting surprised over,
and over, and over,
and over again by these crises
that are very time sensitive.
And then we see somebody go
before Congress and asking
for a billion dollars
to develop a vaccine.
Well, then all the
information that's
associated with that endeavor
starts getting clamped down
and becoming proprietary.
And we had huge trouble
getting information
on what was happening with
the Ebola on the ground
as well as Zika because
of some of the overlays
that were involved
with that process.
And I would ask the audience
the honest to goodness question,
do we have a vaccine available
on the market for Ebola?
Where did that funding go?
Why don't we have a
vaccine for Ebola?
Why don't we have
one for West Nile?
Why don't we have one for SARS?
Why don't we have one for MERS?
Why don't we have one--
I mean so if you
think about this--
and Sanofi backed out of the
Zika vaccine production, right?
So where are we going
with all of this.
Allow me to be the curmudgeon
here and maybe the cynic,
but we have real
problems with how
do we share information
and do the right thing.
And that's why I'm very
animated about this issue,
is that I've seen it play out
over, and over, and over again.
So to me that is the
big research question.
- OK, Yeah, I agree.
There is there's an
organization called
CEPI that was founded
after the Ebola outbreak
and it's an effort to
finance clinical trials
to get some of these potentially
emerging pandemic infections
to develop vaccines for them.
And so that if
something happens,
there's an accelerated
pipeline to get vaccines out.
It's a hard problem to know
which pathogens you choose
and all of those things.
But it's certainly something
we're going to need to tackle.
OK, so I'm going to open it.
Up if you come and line
up behind the microphone
please state your name and
then ask your question.
And we have about 10
minutes for questions.
- Paul [INAUDIBLE] from Tuffs.
Jim, I'd like to ask you
about that whole half, maybe
more of the environment
that wasn't talked about
and that zoonosis.
We aren't coupling with
the veterinary community,
with the zoos, or with all of
the animal side of the kingdom
here, subhuman,
blah, blah, blah.
It seems to me that part
of what you're doing really
needs to be including
that part as well.
You know, for example, the
Journal of Emerging Diseases
from the CDC has been doing
that for the last 10 or 20 years
and in terms of making
those connections.
Any comments on that?
- Do you want me to respond now?
- Let's have a few questions
and then we'll answer them.
- This is sort of a
complicated question.
My name is Alyssa
Goodman and I'm
a professor in the astronomy
department and also
the other science director
here at Radcliffe.
And my question actually
sort of concerns astronomy.
So in astronomy we're known
for sharing our economically
valueless data--
[LAUGHTER]
--very well, actually.
And so I was asked
a few years ago
to give a talk at something
called Sage Bionetworks which
is where a number of the
pharmaceutical companies,
thanks to the efforts
of Stephen Friend,
have volunteered to give
away the data that were not
useful in drug trials.
And it turns out that
this is really helpful.
And so I'm just curious whether
in the world of epidemiology
there's some equivalent of that?
Where some fraction of the
data could be made public
rather than all or nothing?
- Thank you.
- I'd like thank the panel
for your wonderful talks.
Specifically, I'd like
to ask about what I think
is an elephant in the room.
I loved Professor Bhatt's--
Dr. Bhatt's picture
of the elephants.
And that elephant is results
from the intersection
of genetic engineering and
perhaps particularly CRISPR.
Our CRISPR speaker talked
about super villains.
And so my elephant
is the intersection
of genetic engineering,
particularly maybe
CRISPR powered genetic
engineering and bioterrorism,
and how that relates
to your interests
in monitoring and
responding to health crises.
- I'm Ann Patterson.
I work in an organic vegetable
farm, which shows my bias.
Can you give me any
guidance on how to improve
our microbiome by what we eat?
I know you said it was
in the ground water,
but there must be something
we can do about it.
- OK, thank you.
So we'll start with the
question for Jim about zoonosis
and the importance
of monitoring,
being involved with agriculture
and zoos and this kind
of thing.
- So Tracy McNamara from
West Nile virus days
in the Bronx Zoo, she
was the one way back
when who introduced me to
the concept of one health.
So we definitely do.
I was remiss in mentioning that,
so thanks for calling that out.
When we led the
tracking of H5N1 when
it was spreading
throughout Asia,
one of the leading
indicators that we
knew that H5N1 was probably
spreading up into Russia
was the bird die off reports.
We're absolutely on that
page and on board with that.
And honestly, huge
parts of the network
that I monitor on the human
side are veterinarians
and our veterinary researchers.
So we're very close to that.
So thank you for
calling that out.
- So, the next question was
about giving away seemingly
non-useful data and whether
we could do a better job.
I mean, I think we definitely
can do a better job.
And there needs to
be better incentives.
And their responsibility
by researchers like we
saw earlier today to
take it upon themselves
to do a better job with this.
It's very hard as an academic
because your incentives
are squarely in publishing.
And even if it's
not for you, you
want your PhD
students and post-docs
to get their publications out.
Jess do you have
opinions about--
I know you have opinions
about this, so I will ask you.
- So I have one lovely example.
There's a chap called
Hugo Lopez-Gatell who
was a PhD student
at Johns Hopkins
and went to the director
of epidemiology in Mexico
and asked for their childhood
infection and other data.
And the director of
epidemiology told him no.
And later, Hugo Lopez-Gatell
became the director
of epidemiology in Mexico.
[LAUGHTER]
And all that data is
freely available online.
And one of my brilliant
ex graduate students,
Ayesha Mahmud, who's in
the audience here I think,
used all that data for
one of her chapters
of her dissertation.
I think is increasingly moving.
The Pan-American
Health Organization
are real leaders
in this respect.
So many of those countries
share so much of the data.
And many countries
are relatively
relaxed about sharing their
death records, causes of death.
And so there's incredibly
rich data there
which has yet to be mined.
I'm the optimist.
I think that the world
is moving towards this.
And the generation of scientists
that's being trained now
is thinking deeply
about these questions
and tackling these questions.
- And I think digital
platforms for data sharing
are going to be key, especially
for the kind of field
epidemiology that we've
been talking about.
Once things are
digitized we don't
have to go and find
somebody's hand-drawn map
and things can be collated,
and aggregated, and shared
more easily.
Do you have comments on this?
- I think it's critically
important that those data are
shared, but I also
think we need to support
the centralized resources
that host the data sharing.
So from our perspective, we
have open sharing mechanisms
and approaches for
genomic data, but our data
are increasingly growing in
size and are only accelerating.
Right now in the United
States the National Library
of Medicine is charged with
storing all of these data,
but are quite chronically
underfunded for that purpose.
And so I think as we think about
generating these data, which
we most certainly
must and should share,
we need to think about how
we create infrastructures
that allow that.
- Great.
On the question of genetic
engineering and bioterrorism,
I will pass this
to Jim in a second.
I would just say
that like our ability
to prepare for
pandemics globally
and our ability to
detect things that
are going to become
a big problem,
I think the answer
often is health system
strengthening, good access to
health care in low and middle
income settings.
And it comes back to
that over and over again.
We can't detect
anything if we don't
have good data from the field.
But I'm not an expert in
the bioterrorism field
so I'll ask Jim if he'd
like to comment on that one.
- So the way that we detect
unusual events is we're just
looking for unusual
disease, or unusual events
that are recorded.
Unusual social disruption
where we don't expect it.
And then we ask the questions,
then it becomes very forensic.
The hard part here is
putting things in context.
And we have a habit
in this country,
and this goes back
for decades now,
of worrying about biotechnology.
So for those of you who
are old enough in the, room
you remember the
concern about DNA
recombinant technology in the
'70s, and The Andromeda Strain
movie and how it got
everybody spun up
about having
physical containment
level for facilities be created
here in the United States.
So this is a longstanding
thing, and then we
have Hollywood
driving the memes.
So we love to scare
ourselves, we do.
It's our society.
And so if you watch these
events though for 25 years
and you become a
curmudgeon like me,
you realize that we tend to blow
things out of proportion a lot.
So earlier we had a
map posted on Zika
that highlighted
literally half the United
States at risk for Zika.
And we had to
spend a lot of time
around behind the scenes
calming people down and saying,
listen, the probability of a
sustained epidemic of Zika is--
OK, let's be cool about this.
All right, let's be careful
and put things in context.
So I think we do have,
when it comes to CRISPR,
I think we need to slow down.
Let's listen to the researchers.
Let's listen and give
them an opportunity
to engage in the discourse.
And let's not go a little
overboard as we classically do.
My last point would be we
can't even handle game playing
level one, why are we
trying to jack it up to game
playing level number 50?
So we're having a very
hard time managing
the things that are presented
to us by mother nature.
Why do we have to go off
into science fiction land?
So I really, I'm sorry for
taking the pragmatic point
of view, but that's
really after 25 years
that's what it's left me.
- Yeah, and I think
preparing for a pandemic
means preparing for
local epidemics first.
So pandemics start local and
we have to think about it
in that context.
So the last question and
then if we have time,
we'll take a few more, was
about microbiome and diet.
That was for Ami.
- So I think obviously we're
interested in improving
our microbiome, and
I'm glad at least there
are some people in the audience
who resonated with that.
There's limited prospective
data on this topic.
Certainly many espouse eating
diverse fiber rich diet
as a method for potentially
returning to an increased
diversity of the microbiome.
I certainly think,
as a physician,
minimizing exposure to
unnecessary antibiotics
is critical.
And I've seen certainly a
shift from five years ago
when you have sniffles, you go
in, you ask for your Z-Pack.
To people coming in
and really saying,
well, I don't think I
need a Z-Pack, which
I think is part of the answer.
Obviously we have
antibiotic use that's
broad scale in, for example,
the livestock industry.
And you heard a little bit about
other household antimicrobials.
You know, curtailing
use of these
is much more of a global
issue than a local issue.
Bu I think it begins with
consumers asking what
the potential for harm
is with novel agents that
are introduced into
the commercial sector.
And so I think being smart
consumers can certainly
contribute.
But I think those are
some of the things
that we can do as we
consider our microbiome.
And I think the first
step toward improvement
is obviously awareness.
- OK.
I've been told we have one more
time for one more question.
- Cynthia [INAUDIBLE]
from Brandeis University.
And I was wondering--
I think maybe this question is
mostly for Jim-- but are you
doing any work with
tuberculosis because it's
the leading infectious
killer in the world,
and between 30% and
40% of all deaths
due to antimicrobial
resistant bugs
are due to drug resistant TB.
And do we not track it
anymore because we just
know that it's endemic and it's
going to kill a ton of people
and given up on them?
Or what's the scenario from
your perspective of pretty much
any of your work, but I
think maybe especially Jim.
- Well, so our bias
here is we look
at abrupt shifts in
indicators that that show us
that a community is suddenly
experiencing something
that's acutely happening.
And in the tuberculosis
world, like with HIV, malaria,
and so these other
endemic diseases
in endemic areas
of the world, we
see very calm
disruption patterns.
So these are
communities that are
used to dealing
with these issues,
they're de-sensitized
even though there's
a lot of mortality.
What we do see are cases where--
and we know it's just
the tip of the iceberg.
I mean, we have data problems
just like everybody else does.
But where an XDR TB will show
up in a clinic in South Africa
and people will realize
that, oh my gosh,
we're dealing with a patient
that can't be treated.
And then people
evacuate the facility,
potentially spreading
that into the community.
And so we've detected
that periodically.
We know there's a lot
that we don't detect.
And yeah, it's a huge issue.
I mean, we've all discussed
the issues of access
to data, which kind of
drives everything and drives
our awareness.
But the classic mantra
in public health
is, if you don't report
it, it doesn't exist.
- And I would just
add that there
are significant pushes to
end TB, and malaria, and HIV.
And you know we've been talking
about an explosive epidemic
event, but actually there
are these very long time
endemic infections that
cause a huge amount
morbidity and
mortality and continue
to place enormous economic
burden on low and middle income
settings.
Those movements with genomics
and all of the methods
that we've been
talking about are
hard for these infections
that have long, chronic latent
periods.
But there's certainly
a whole range
of people who are trying
to push for ultimately
eradication of those things.
We've only managed to
eradicate two pathogens.
We're struggling to do
so for the third, polio.
But that is definitely
on the agenda,
I think, for most people.
It's a really tough
challenge though.
I don't know if Jess, you
want to talk about TB.
- I was just going to mention
that genomics as well.
Although it's very
hard to detect TB
through case detection
just because it
is this chronic pathogen.
We can trace back
by looking at the genomics and
trying to understand patterns
of spread.
And that, again, speaks
to health care capacity
and where you need
reinforcements.
So it is a hidden
epidemic but it's one
that we are using the lens
of things like, I mean,
to use the big data
buzz word again
is being used to approach
these challenges.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- OK, we're getting
flashing red lights.
I'd like to thank all
the speakers once again.
[APPLAUSE]